I hope you're ready because this is a
little bit jarring when you turn this
corner you are stepping on to the USS
Enterprise this soundstages laid out
exactly the way the original series
soundstage was had you gone to Desilu 50
years ago you would have found that the
original series sets were laid out
interconnected exactly the way you are
about to see them we put a lot of effort
into trying to duplicate the sets as
closely as possible to the original
series in 1968 when we first walked onto
these Star Trek sets it it was
incredible
now the first room we're gonna come to
if you see it probably is the biggest
clue that it's going to be sick of it
you walk through here here is the whole
sickbay now I like coming back here
because this is you swing around here
and this is the iconic shot that people
remember of sick bay
right we come out of sick bay we take a
left and we find ourselves immediately
at a short hallway
what's down this hallway mmm one of the
favorite sets in Star Trek the
transporter room
the original transporter pads these
babies were actually Fornell lenses they
were movie lenses we actually borrowed
an actual for Nolan's
the the same size as the one they used
and then we did a resin casting of it so
all of these are resin castings of
original lenses and then we cut holes
out of the floor and we lift them from
underneath so we continue down the
corridor and and this is really amazing
here if you start looking down you can
start seeing the whole big bending
beautiful length of the thing what's
really special about this corridor is
that you can shoot from either end and
and you don't run out of space I got to
tell you about this this hexagonal mesh
it was all over the place in the
original series you saw it in
engineering auxilary control well when
you decide you want to find it it's
really hard to find it's very very heavy
and actually what it is it's it's
grating that was used to support big
cement
we continue down wall pieces like this
Jeff Johnson one of our dear friends
built this that kind of attention to
detail that if you just happen to catch
things in the background of a shot and
like oh my gosh that looks just like it
well a lot of time and effort went into
making sure that that happened you
probably saw this sitting in the in the
corridor in the original series it was
actually a ceramic pot and it was kind
of bell shaped and we couldn't really
find one no matter how hard we tried
so I actually bought if you figured it
out this is a lampshade that's also bell
shaped and we painted it put a little
detail on it and it works just fine now
if you look to the right here you'll see
Denton and AH the Jefferies tube this is
an iconic piece of Star Trek right here
and again several of our amazing
artisans Scott Granger Ralph Miller a
lot of them put a lot of work into
recreating this as beautifully as it is
I think our most one of our most
challenging sets to do was the Jefferies
tube here we took a 42 inch - had to cut
it at a 45 degree and then we had to
figure out how to get it to stay at that
45 degrees and it had to be 18 inches
off the floor
it couldn't be 18 and a half couldn't be
19 had to be 18 inches off - I think
it's time to show you the big enchilada
just like in the original series the
bridge was set off in a corner by itself
just to exactly the way our studio is
set up the bridge of the enterprise
beautiful beautiful beautiful so much
work has gone into this
you guys I couldn't even begin to tell
you
Mike Bednar John brought the people at
Farragut built this bridge a few years
ago and and I came down to direct an
episode for them and we all hit it off
and became great friends and decided we
were going to do something together the
detail is unbelievable the viewer we're
here something really nerdy most people
when they build this it's just one solid
piece that goes around and around and
around oh no no we have crazy people
working here who are gonna make sure
it's accurate all three of these disks
rotate independently all of these lights
flashing back here behind behind these
panels is the work of our master a
director of photography Matt Busey is
one of the most brilliant wonderful
people I know and we came down here once
or like man someday we need to get these
lights flashing and Matt made the
mistake of saying I can do that I
started looking into how to illuminate
these things and you know everyone's
like we'll just put Christmas lights
back there but I wanted to have the same
kind of patterns that they had in the
original show problem I found is that
all the controllers on the market use a
technique called multiplexing which
blinks the LEDs very quickly so I was
like all right I'm just gonna teach
myself electronic of course you step
down here you get to Sulu station Chekov
station and then finally to the
captain's chair which is everybody's
favorite place to sit when we have tours
and and visitors come to visit the set
they're mildly interested in the sickbay
and they're you're mildly curious about
the corridor but everybody wants to see
the bridge and set the captain's chair
for more behind-the-scenes action of
Star Trek continues subscribe to the
wired Channel